hi it's matthew martin from details and
i just saw the long vent collection
which was a little harder this season
but still retained its elegant feel
my favorite piece was the puffer hybrid
trench coat that had this sporty slash
tailored mix which i thought was a
really modern take on a classic
outerwear piece you had the nylon and
the poopiness of a puffer mixed with the
streamlined silhouette of the trench and
i thought the two went together really
nicely
a lot of the outerwear had this amazing
sloped shoulder where the seam of the
shoulder fell off the top of the arm
that gave a really nice interesting
shape to the look especially when paired
with a super skinny pant
a lot of the trousers this season were
flared and had a very 70s feel however
the higher waist of the trousers made
them feel a lot more modern and current
and this season long van gave us an
update on the briefcase they were all
extremely slim and very narrow which i
thought was a really nice minimal
message especially in contrast with a
lot of the fuller proportions of the
clothing
the show closed with a lot of high-top
white sneakers which were paired with
the evening wear and i thought that was
a really fresh update to an evening look
for more videos from paris check out
details.com and follow me on twitter at
details matt